[Música]
hola
desde que yo nací no he parado de
moverme yo soy una persona que me
encanta pararme de manos y hacer vueltas
de carreta en eso a lo largo de los años
resulta un poco esto hermoso sobre todo
a la gente que está alrededor de uno
como mis hermanas que siempre dicen como
ya que ese quieta
a mí me cuenta que chiquitita yo ama y
acompañarla al supermercado y en cada
pasillo corría y hacía vueltas de
carreta un día había una exhibición de
artesanías y habían como en un stand
como unos figurines y obviamente yo salí
corriendo y de una vuelta carreta me
volé toda la artesanía todo se quebró y
le pagaron la factura y yo no no me
acuerdo
o decidí no acordarme no sé pero pero sí
sé que constantemente me decían como me
la quedé quieta y yo creo que esta
energía fue la que me llevó hace 10 años
a tomar la decisión de dejar mi trabajo
en banca por dedicarme a bailar
y realmente cambie todos los vestidos
las enaguas y los tacones y normalmente
yo siempre ando así en medias funde una
escuela donde hoy bailo y doy clases y
es por esta razón que yo tengo contacto
con por lo menos 50 estudiantes
diferentes todos los días estos
estudiantes en su mayoría son mujeres
desde unas gemelitas que llegan de tres
años en pañales hasta adultas mayores
y por eso a lo largo de los años nos
hemos dado cuenta que a través de las
clases en conversaciones en los pasillos
a través de actividades que planeamos
hemos empoderado a un montón de mujeres
hemos ayudado a niñas a tener mayor
confianza en sí mismas a ser más fuertes
hasta hemos ayudado a mujeres que podría
decir con seguridad que recuperen
felicidad en sus vidas y lo digo con
convicción y con seriedad porque
realmente he vivido esto muchísimas
veces este año en el empezando en 2018
hasta la fecha hemos sido el ancla y una
plataforma de ayuda y de apoyo a una
alumna queridísima de 13 años a combatir
un cáncer
y es por eso que estos espacios de
educación no tradicional son sumamente
importantes como plataformas para
empoderar
realmente
yo me dado cuenta o nos hemos dado
cuenta que en estos espacios donde hay
líderes y donde hay un alcance a un
volumen significativo de personas es
nuestra responsabilidad empodera reglas
y estos espacios no tradicionales
educativos alguna vez algunas veces son
subestimados y para mí es todo lo
contrario son sumamente importantes son
sumamente importantes replicar estos
modelos no solo en el mundo del
movimiento sino que en cualquier otra
disciplina siempre y cuando cumplan con
cuatro características primera
característica es que sean espacios de
comunidad y colaboración a mí se me
endulza demasiado el corazón cuando yo
llego a la recepción y veo a una prisa y
32 años explicándole geometría a una luz
y de 14 años o veo a una hija de 12 años
poniéndole las zapatillas a una julia de
4 años para que vaya a su clase de baby
jazz
súper bien
otra característica super importante es
que estos espacios sean de liderazgo
pero que vean las necesidades
individuales de las personas todos aquí
aprendemos de manera diferente hay
estudiantes que aprenden con una
instrucción verbal hay otros estudiantes
que aprenden con la música se les es más
fácil otros que aprenden por medio de
una demostración otros que necesitan
como yo hacer como los movimientos una y
otra y otra vez para realmente poder
aprenderlos y hay estudiantes que en un
día sacan todas las coreos y hay
estudiantes que le toman cinco meses y
todo eso es válido y todo eso hay que
respetarlo
mi característica favorita es que estos
espacios se deben de enfocar en lo que
es la excelencia y no la perfección los
procesos de aprendizaje y de enseñanza
donde el objetivo es la perfección son
super frustrantes y super angustiantes
porque porque nadie es perfecto o sea
eso es imposible no se puede llegar a
esos a esos puntos
en cambio la excelencia nos enseña a ser
disciplinados nos enseña a ser
esforzados siempre dentro del marco de
nuestras capacidades
la última característica que es la más
importante es que para empoderar a las
personas tiene que existir el reto
a todos los estudiantes que yo les daba
clases no los motiva o los empodera
pegarse la pierna a la nariz o hacer un
split o de repente hacer 5 piruetas
girar y girar y girar es uno de lo que
realmente los motiva los motiva que haya
un reto y que se sientan capaces que se
sientan ágiles que se sientan libres que
se conecten con su niño interior que que
se conecten con esa sensibilidad que nos
convierte a todos en artistas por eso
hoy sabemos bueno quiero demostrar todo
esto que acabo de decir por medio del
movimiento obvio vamos a hacer un a
presentarles una coreografía invitamos e
invitamos al ensamble que es el grupo de
adolescentes con el que yo paso más
tiempo en mi semana mucho más que con mi
familia
y ellas están en una edad que la
adolescencia que es un poco complicada o
particular entonces esta guía y este
empoderamiento tiene que ser el triple
'hemos
y coreografiado un número que trata
sobre la búsqueda de la autenticidad
fuera de los marcos de una sociedad nos
inspiramos en un autorretrato de vincent
van gogh y hemos estado discutiendo con
ellas cómo es que nos percibimos a
nosotras mismas
no quiero decirles más para que también
ustedes que ustedes su propia
interpretación pero sí me gustaría
despedirme con el movimiento porque
siento que con el movimiento siempre
puedo ir mucho más allá muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
y
[Música]
sí
bien
no
a mí
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
e
bueno
más